hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren in der heutigen gesellschaft in
der heutigen zeit bei all dem stress et
cetera ist entspannung etwas was
wirklich sehr häufig zu kurz kommen
daher spielen wir heute zusammen das
spiel flower bei dem spiel flower geht
es darum dass wir eine kleine blüte sind
und wir müssen den blumen entlang uns
einen weg durch die natur bahnen und das
ganze eigentlich schnellstmöglich
schaffen also die blumen leiten uns hier
so ein bisschen zeigen uns den weg wo
wir lang fliegen sollen ich hab mich
verfahren
es ist so eine art religion zwar müssen
wir den ganzen blumen hier lang fliegen
jede blume die wir erreicht haben die
wird sich dann so öffnen und wird uns
einen neuen abschnitt freischalten
beispiel hier vorne haben wir jetzt
blaue blüten und wenn wir alle blauen
blüten hier in dem kreis absolviert
haben dann sehen wir schon eine kurze
animation und sehen dass die windräder
beispielsweise hier vorne anfangen sich
zu drehen dass diesen kleinen teil haben
wir schon geschafft von dem level und
nun geht es weiter für unsere
blütenblätter das heißt wir sehen hier
vorne schon die nächsten blumen müssen
hier unseren weg lang fliegen und haben
jetzt hier vorne
ja keine ahnung was jetzt passiert ist
wir müssen auf jeden fall nach und nach
diese blüten hier öffnen jetzt mit
fliege auf meiner hand und somit den weg
zu der and region freischalten mehr oder
weniger das war zum beispiel vorhin
zwischen region war das mit den
windrädern wo die windräder dann
angefangen haben mit ihrem wind sich zu
drehen hier vorne dreht jetzt auch ein
neues windrad und das drehen dieser
windräder zeigt uns dass wir einen neuen
bereich freigeschaltet haben zum
beispiel jetzt hier vorne
seht ihr schon da kommen wir nicht
weiter weil hier so ein gegenwind kommt
das heißt wir müssen jetzt wieder zu
blumen hinfliegen die wir noch nicht
geöffnet haben das sind zum beispiel die
hier vorne da fliegen weil es lange hier
vorne den weg entlang und hier vorne
haben wir die nächsten blumen die öffnen
weil es auch noch geben und somit
schalten wir nach und nach die neuen
regionen dieser welt hier frei die sache
ist dass dieses level was ich gerade
spiele nicht das erste level in diesem
spiel ist denn ich habe schon das erste
und zweite level gespielt sondern das
hier ist schon das dritte level und ich
glaube auch das letzte level in diesem
spiel
das ganze ist ein spiel das heißt flower
und es kostet wirklich fünf euro hart
günstig ich habe die ersten beiden level
früher gespielt als sie noch studiert
habe und nebenbei da noch ein praktikum
gemacht habe und youtube nebenbei hatte
da ist wirklich sonst spiel etwas weiß
ich nicht so er hat ja schon in die
musik
und mit den blumen ist herzlich
besteuert an aber es bringt ein wirklich
runter das heutige video ist ein ganz
ganz anderes video als das video was
sich zum beispiel gestern hochgeladen
habe gestern habe ich ja auch das
make-up routine reagiert also eine
reaction wo ich wirklich die ganze zeit
gelacht habe und so weiter und so fort
bis heute ist wirklich eher so ein
entspannungs video und sie merkt ja
schon ich kommentiere auch so ein
bisschen anders ich hatte erst überlegt
ob ich dieses video nutzung war ein
thema zu reden weil das hier eigentlich
perfekt dafür gemacht ist aber ich habe
mir gedacht ich zeige euch einfach das
spiel so ein bisschen das ist von epic
games also von den leuten jedoch fordert
gemacht haben ist überhaupt keine
bezahlte werbung hier oder so also ich
bekomme hier kein geld für das ich euch
das spiel nahe lege ich finde nur dass
es ein sehr sehr schönes spiel ist es
gibt keine große story man ist halt wie
gesagt einfach zu beginnen so ein
kleines blütenblatt und muss sich seinen
weg bahnen und sich mehr und mehr
blütenblätter hole mittlerweile also ich
bin im dritten level ich hab schon so
einige blüten blätter am start
red flexpod ok dieses spiel ist einfach
ein spiel was mich immer sehr sehr krass
runter bringt also sei es jetzt ob ich
das ganze kommentiere und aufnehme oder
ob ich das ganze nur einfach so privat
spiele es ist einfach ich weiß nicht
wenn ich mir das so anschaue
keine ahnung ich finds ich finde es
einfach schön glaube ich bin der einzige
mensch der das entspannend findet ich
bin zum beispiel auch jemand der sehr
sehr gut einschlafen kann bei regen
geräuschen oder der auch sehr gut
einschlafen kann bei irgendwie wasser
geräuschen oder irgendwie sowas dadurch
beispielsweise früher einmal auch eine
app die einen abends die muss man unter
das kopfkissen legen und die macht einem
zur geräusche von so fügen
und wasserfällen und so windig mega mega
schön und mega entspannend gerade auch
zum einschlafen und auch gerade in einer
zeit wo es zum beispiel sehr sehr
hektisch ist oder sogar vorne haben
jetzt auch erstmal noch ein paar blumen
die müssen wir erstmal noch öffnen
ich frage mich ob ich nicht mittlerweile
mal alle geöffnet habe also da hinten
sind auch noch welche da kommen wir
allerdings nicht hin weil ihr seht schon
da bleibt uns der winter wir können ja
auch so ein bisschen mal höher fliegen
dann könnt ihr euch das ganze mal von
oben anschauen
da sieht man richtig dass das hier
wirklich sein kurs ist den man
eigentlich lang fliegen muss die sache
ist nur ich weiß nicht welche ist ich
blumen mich hier noch nicht geöffnet
habe schreibt mir mal gerne in die
kommentare was euch runter bringt wenn
ihr stress habt also jetzt gerade habe
ich keine richtigen stressig fall zu
einer halben stunde zu meinen eltern und
möchte hier mal eben noch ein video
aufnehmen für euch morgen dass ihr auch
ein video habt aber ich hab halt sehr
viel so ja so viel gedanken stress ist
das nicht meine es geht einfach gerade
sehr sehr viel ab in meinem leben und
stress ist ja auch nicht immer negativ
sondern es gibt ja auch positiven stress
also stress muss nicht immer nur
schlechter stress sein wie
beispielsweise man muss lernen für ihn
eine arbeit oder man muss ja etwas
negatives machen sondern es gibt auch
positiven stress und das ist glaube ich
das was ich gerade habe wir sind gerade
drauf und dran umzuziehen in den
nächsten monaten irgendwann und das sind
so sachen voll vermisst so einfach so zu
reden ich weiß nicht ich finde das voll
schön gerade ist halt wirklich ein
komplett anderes video als der content
den ich sonst auf meinem kanal bringe
aber ich finds ehrlich gesagt ganz schön
und main kanal lebte hier vorne haben
wir noch ein paar blüten mich habt euch
versteck gerade abwechslung ist ja etwas
was ich auf meinem kanal sehr sehr doll
präge beziehungsweise was ja eigentlich
erlaubt sind meine des kanals ist hier
vorne geht jetzt erst mal noch der wind
durch das heißt da sind neue blüten zu
dem wir hinfliegen müssen main kanal
lebt von abwechslung also beispielsweise
gestern kam er wie bereits gesagt noch
diese domain reaction wo ich auf dauer
reagiert habe wie sie halt wirklich ja
sich dumm schminkt aber jetzt heute
kommen zum beispiel dieses video hier wo
war mein gott was geht jetzt mit dem
blue me ab heute kommt jetzt ein ganz
anderes video einfach wie
sonst besonnen blumen spiel spielen
sonst our game wo es einfach darum geht
dass der wind wieder durch die windräder
pustet und wir sehen schon das windrad
hier fährt sich weiß das heißt wir haben
den neuen abschnitt des levels
freigeschaltet
das ding ist das ist wirklich zu diesem
spiel hier ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht
es gibt hier wirklich speed runs als man
kann ja auch so ganz schnell durch
fliegen und die ganzen blumen öffnen und
dann gibt's wirklich zeiten mit denen
sich dann leute messen et cetera pp das
ist aber meiner ansicht nach gar nicht
der sinn dieses spiels also klar ich
kann jetzt auch mit einem gewissen speed
ihr einfach die ganze zeit durch fliegen
oder nehme ich ihnen noch die ganzen
blauen blumen mit und dann fliege ich
hier weiter schnell durch und die andere
seite noch die und dann hier über den
berg und dann sind hier die habe ich
vergessen da so gut bin ich jetzt auch
wieder nicht aber ich finde wirklich was
dieses spiel so einzigartig macht es
einfach ich bin einfach mal ruhig kurz
[Musik]
also
versteht ihr was ich meine sind einfach
schön diese diese klänge und dann fliegt
man hier unten lecher schon wieder
blumen vergessen man fliegt hier unten
langen die blumen öffnen sich für jede
geöffnete blume ertönt auch ein neuer
sound jetzt hab ich die da oben auch
schon wieder vergessen für jede
geöffnete blume ertönt ein neuer sound
ms kommen neue töne dazu und allgemein
die ganze kulisse hier wie die
blütenblätter dadurch fliegen jetzt in
welche vorne im neuen leveln meter
weiter steuern hier unten lang ich finde
dass das ganze wirklich kein spiel ist
was man sehr schnell selber war ich
nicht schon weiß ich noch nicht das
neueste ja das neue sam ich finde dass
das ganze spiel kein spiel ist wo man so
schnell hierdurch fliegt ist dass ich
mein ich finde das ist ein spiel wo man
sich zeit lassen ein bisschen hierdurch
günstig zum beispiel hatte auch früher
als bildschirmhintergrund auf meinem
rechner damals ein aquarium nicht mit
echten fischen der natürlich nicht mit
echten fischen warm and computer aber
mit computeranimierten fischen die dann
irgendwie her geschwommen sind und ich
fand es einfach beruhigend mir das
anzuschauen und ich war auch früher mal
auf einer webseite hieß raney mut ich
weiß nicht ob wir die kennt das ist eine
website da kann man einfach drauf gehen
und man hört einfach nur trägen
geräusche und ich finde das ist gerade
wenn man lernt oder so ist es etwas was
einem unheimlich hilft oder auch wenn
man entspannen will und ich habe es
jetzt auch mal das ziel gefasst dass wir
demnächst so ein bisschen mit yoga
anfangen wollten also dass wir gerade
echt gut hier neben beine
es ist was passiert ich nehme hier so
ein bisschen anlauf und kommen hier von
der seite und ich wollte nur mal aufs
thema zurückzukommen und auch dem
nächsten dem yoga studio in köln
anmelden weil ich glaube auch yoga ist
etwas was ich sehe wirklich früher leute
aus gelacht habe muss ich wirklich
zugeben die yoga gemacht haben aber
mittlerweile ist es was ein glaube ich
was passieren er hat die zeit so ein
bisschen gezeigt dass entspannung etwas
ist auch dass man genauso achten sollte
wie auch beispielsweise wenn man eine
klausur oder eine klassenarbeit anstehen
hat jetzt hier vorne
die die winde gehen in das riesenrad
riesenrad wahrscheinlich luca gerade die
zeit in meinem leben wo ich mehr oder
weniger so ein burnout hatte so ein
holiday syndrom hatte ja damals die
videos gemacht jetzt hier vorne auch
wieder die töne
es ist einfach ich weiß nicht ich finde
es einfach beruhigend dass sich gerade
sagen wollte war dass gerade diese zeit
wo ich so viel stress hatte mit studium
praktikum et cetera dass mir die zeit
einfach gezeigt hat ja man sollte nicht
nur die sachen vor augen haben die man
gerade vor augen hat wie beispielsweise
klausuren und stress in der schule oder
bei der arbeit sondern man muss immer
noch auf die andere komponente achten
und das ist der eigene körper und das
ist wirklich das aller aller wichtigste
und um jetzt mal ganz grob
zurückzukommen hier nachdem ich mich
wirklich komplett in diesem thema
entspannung schön stress et cetera
verloren habe
das ist für mich so ein bisschen der
sinn des spiels man hört einfach die
musik ich habe jetzt auch nicht mal eine
typische komische clowns musik hier
immerhin hintergrund gepackt oder sowas
sondern es geht wirklich darum dass man
sich hier mal die musik anhört dass man
einfach wenn man sich das hier mal
anschaut ich finde gerade wenn man in
der großstadt wohnt und man nicht so
diese riesigen grünflächen hat zum
entspannen oder zum hinlegen ist dass
hier was so ein spiel was einem roman
eintauchen kann wissen was ich meine
es gibt sogar noch ein viertes level
sehe ich gerade also dafür dass das
spiel wirklich nur fünf euro kostet ist
es doch noch recht umfangreich an der
stelle ich das heute wieder jetzt
allerdings auch beendet meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
würde ich mich selber einen daumen hoch
freuen
das heutige video war wirklich sehr sehr
anders als der content den die sonst auf
einem kanal bringe weil es heute ja es
war nicht viel mit rum schneiden und
zack zack jump cuts und einblendungen
und clowns musik die ganze zeit denn es
ging um entspannung und so ein bisschen
reden ich weiß es sich sehr häufig vom
thema abgekommen bin heute und das tut
mir auch leid aber ich möchte euch
einfach sagen hey wenn ihr stress in der
schule hatten oder stress mit freunden
oder blah blah blah ganz viele dinge
brauchen kopf rum vergesst nicht euren
körper entspannung heißt auch einfach
mal nichts machen für mich ist es so
dass so ein spiel mit sehr sehr
entspannt oder ein film oder ein buch
lesen
bei anderen leuten ist es so dass wenn
sie mit dem hund rausgehen oder wenn die
einfach nur die ferne schauen aber leute
achtet auf euren körper und das ist ein
bisschen die message vom heutigen video
morgen geht es normal weiter mit einem
dummen luca video
[Musik]
ein